Good
morning. We are back live.
Hi. Quick morning session right
now. Just like a half hour stream and uh
we're going to be looking at the results
from last night's experiments. Launching
a few new ones. I'll grab breakfast and
then we will come back and be here for
the whole rest of the day working on
various bits of research.
stuff. We have
here the full completed maze
runs.
90% on mazes is very very good. These
are very good
results. I'd like to see some of the
curves.
We
do few too
many
7% other nine runs. This is a reasonable
number. These are
reasonable. We look at the hyperparams
for this.
cool. I actually think we can just like
set up the uh the meta sweep,
right? Probably just set up the meta
sweep right now.
set, I
believe. I forget what machine we have
this set up to run on, though. meta to
run on
specifically. Uh, we do have meta, but
we don't even have Python 311 on this
box.
Let's try the other
one. We have
Metagrid. We do not have Python 311 on
this
either. That's a little silly.
May as well get it set up on on the big
box
idea. And let's see if we can just in
the next 15 minutes or so, 20 minutes,
get a a sweep running on meta. That
would be the best.
right?
Oh, 3.4 terabytes of experiments.
Lovely. That is from old
uh errors on the way that we were saving
models.
Yeah, this already exists
anyways. We don't need to update
alternatives. We do need this. And I
believe
it's CUDA 128, right? Let's
311. I don't actually know what the best
way is to manage all this crap, right?
Like we don't want to distribute a
docker that has a massive docker that
has 311 12 13 and stuff on it, do
we? I don't know. Maybe we do. Maybe it
is better to just have a docker and be
done. That does kind of appeal to me.
The only trade-off is download size.
we can figure out like what the
difference would be in in file size,
right? Because
like I think most of this space comes
from base CUDA which you only need the
one version for your GPU
of. Welcome Twitch
folks. The plan for uh right now is to
get actually I can show off the
environment that we're going to be
running sweeps on.
is Okay, they massively changed the
graphic since I last looked at it. It
looks like they got themselves an
artist. Very nice. Um, cool. So, yeah,
it's this grid- based environment where
you have like resources. You convert
resources to different
types. This is very cool.
I was
like, I looked at this and I immediately
get like Binding of Isaac vibes. Maybe
it's just because of the
character. Anyone else? This is like
total Binding of Isaac vibes, right?
trails. Oh, they're doing something
different with this because they have
And this would look so much better with
smooth graphics.
now.
Oops. Hang
on. We on the right
where we're just going to actually like
regrab our fork in
That should be the Syon build and any
other things that we
need we will install
separate. I don't want to install their
requirements file because it like
installs annoying versions of torch and
stuff.
Oh, also the guys that build uh this
Metagrid environment are hiring quite a
bit right now. So, if you're looking for
a way to get a cool job in RL, doing
some open source contributions, pretty
good
idea. Now, Puffer is not exactly hiring
full-time, but we do pull in uh major
contributors for contract work.
Do I need
scypiestats? I think that's a dead
dependency. That would be a good thing
for me to do clean up on just like
really cut down number of depths for
puffer.
Right. We do need to do the jank build
stuff. There's some jank build stuff to
be done.
I think that this is the torch
extensions being
weird. So, I need to like make this
whole setup file work better.
Okay. Yeah. So, this is going to build
torch
extensions. I'm really sick of all this
silly packaging and like cleanup work. I
think probably what I will do is in
between the next puffer release and um
when I start doing algorithm work, I'll
probably take like a couple days off off
and then take a few days to like just
build some little cool toy environment.
Just like think of some fun thing to do
for Puffer that would like give us
another thing just to like
mentally get out of this and really
start like enjoying the stuff a lot
If this starts installing torch, I'm
killing it.
I don't know why I did that. It's
already installed.
bad. Uh I think the package is not
called Hydra, right?
core. Okay, we do run the
environment and we do get stats
out. So what we are going to do
now, we have this nice new uh sweep
configuration
here. Commented update epochs.
mini batch
size kind of
wrong. We're going to do is we're just
going to
delete all these defaults.
from 100 mil
to 400 mil maybe.
unit 200
mil auto
scale and then we will see what this
does.
288. Oh no, that's max and mean. Yeah,
this is
want? which let's see 16 128 * 16 agents
per n is way too
small. We would ideally like this to
be 4x
larger. So this is going to be
environments batch size of
config completely unbottlenecked.
Oh, okay.
speed. I believe we no longer sweep
these things, right?
EFFI. Um, why do I have Rust errors in
my code? Hey, Boxing.
Why do I have Rust
errors? Oh, Neptune uses Rust,
huh? So, this is probably like a login
thing. Okay, I like Neptune less because
Rust
start. Is this like all of Neptune right
now?
Python API call
failed. Well, that
sucks. I haven't tested the wand in a
while. Does it work?
The heck is this? CFI back end.
Oh.
Uh, probably just install CFFI,
right?
Okay, that was a little silly of me.
Boom. And if this works, then I go for
breakfast and I will be back for the
whole rest of the day
thereafter.
650k. Lovely.
good. So, this will run a sweep and then
I will be be uh I will be back after
breakfast and we will continue working
on all of the pre-release stuff. If
Spencer's around, maybe we'll do some
stuff on GPU drive. If Captain's around,
maybe we'll do stuff on impulse wars.
But generally, it's going to be a cycle
of like have sweeps going in the
background, make sure that the results
are good, keep improving stuff, and then
like keep just simplifying,
streamlining, error checking all the
stuff in main puffer lib. Uh yeah, so
thank you and I will be Oh, one thing
before I go. Did we hit 2k stars
officially?
one star off of 2K. Start it if you
haven't. All right. Thanks.